all right he's a pro football hall of
famer and i figured let's get him on not
only uh because uh he has a unique
perspective on tom brady because he um
he lost to brady in brady's first super
bowl win
but he also knows about second acts and
he's just a great human on the planet
and also uh called on westwood one the
rams win
over the 49ers on sunday and is going to
call uh super bowl 56 and so fi stadium
in a couple sundays for westwood one
he's kurt warner how are you doing kurt
i'm doing good my friend how are you i'm
doing great what do you think brady's
now retired
what do you say about that i mean i
think i think like all of us as fans you
know you're kind of bummed um you know
because every year it's been so much fun
to watch him and watch him as you said
reinvent himself and what is he gonna do
next and you know everybody i think
waiting for him to
to fall off
uh you know the flat part of the earth
and and disappear and not be able to
play like he did and he finishes with
you know number one and so many
different categories this year and
you're just like it's it's just
unbelievable and it's fun and it was a
part of our nfl that you said okay this
is the one constant that we know every
year is tom brady's gonna have a chance
to compete for the super bowl now now
who else is in the mix so i think as a
fan we're all kind of bummed um
as a fan as we talked about on our our
you know show the other day is that
we're all very thankful um you know not
very long very often do you get a chance
to you know witness
the entirety of a career of you know
what i think most of us believe is the
greatest
football player to ever play and you
know as you said i got to see it up
close and personal at the beginning uh
i've been able to watch it ever since
uh and been in amazement so often of
you know what he's done and yeah i made
the point on on our show also that
the thing about tom brady is that
he made it seem so easy you know when we
talk about ten super bowls we talk about
winning seven and you talk about you
know 14 championship games and all of
this stuff
that you know we just kind of flippantly
throw around because it's tom brady
and you know then you can you know i i
feel for so fortunate to have played in
three super bowls drew brees got to play
in one aaron rodgers has played in one
when you start to put it in perspective
of how easy he made it and and what he
accomplished on the whole uh and you
know i think in an era also you're
talking about in an era where we had
other greats you had peyton manning you
had ben brothersberger who just retired
he had you know breeze and rogers as i
talked about i mean you talked about
some of the greatest quarterbacks we've
ever seen in this game and it was during
that era where tom brady did all of this
and so you know that to me as a player
when you don't understand how difficult
it is to get there one time or to
compete at that level consistently year
in and year out
is probably what i was most in awe of
with tom brady because we all sit back
and go i wish i would have had one more
opportunity to do that and he just made
it look routine every year that this is
where i'm gonna be i'm gonna at least be
in the afc championship game and i'm
probably gonna be in the super bowl and
that just doesn't happen in any sport
and you know and again it's the ultimate
team sport we understand that it takes a
team to win championships but that guy
and that leader that you have that you
believe in that you believe every time
you step on the field you're gonna win
uh is a difference maker and that's why
you know super bowls and wins get
connected to quarterbacks because those
guys are the difference makers and he
just did it better than everyone else
and so i'm just i'm thankful that i got
to witness it uh you know if you've got
to get beat by somebody in the super
bowl you know it's okay to say i got
beat by tom brady um and it's been it's
been a joy to watch him and and i feel
like he's always done it the right way
too uh he's always done it with class
and carried himself uh that way and so
just uh it's an honor to have competed
against him to watch his to have watched
his career um and uh and to know him as
a friend you know what and and there's
so many ways to follow up here so i'm
gonna i'm gonna go i guess i got like
two or three follow-ups i'm gonna take
the first one here about back in the day
um
so you know super bowl is not any normal
game where you're just warming up and
just chit-chatting but did you speak to
brady before when he was just a kid
looking for his first and you're that
guy two years removed from the magic
carpet ride that by the way is in
theaters near you an american underdog
terrific movie so did you have a
conversation with him well we spoke a
little was a little bit because we
played earlier that year
um
in new england and so we had played once
that year and so we spoke a little bit
you know he kind of came on the scene
similar to the way i did um and just you
know kind of encouraged him and said hey
you know you're doing a great job keep
it up you never know what you know
possibilities are i mean you look at me
uh but you know not a long conversation
but just kind of that introductory
conversation you know with a young kid
and then we didn't speak before the
super bowl uh but talked afterwards and
uh you know just one of those things
that again at the time you know
you're disappointed for yourself um you
know for whatever you can be happy for a
young kid that gets the opportunity and
and does great and wins the super bowl
you're happy for them but you know let's
be honest i mean i didn't see any of
this coming in that game you know he
threw for like 150 yards and you know
had a great drive at the end to kind of
put him over the top um but you know it
wasn't this tom brady and so i got a
chance to kind of see
that and see him win uh as being a
complimentary piece and and just a part
of a team to becoming the tom brady that
we know that that led teams and carried
teams
to that point and so um yeah we had some
initial you know simple conversations um
but but never with any inkling of what
was ahead uh for him well i mean and and
we we
may see you know somebody have their
career start similar to brady's uh
although we're still waiting to somebody
to go back to back as he did three in
his first
four years winning it all and joe burrow
has an opportunity coming up shortly to
to get on that road
but i don't know if we'll ever see
anybody again do what he did after the
age of 37 and played a 44 and look as
great as doing it i wonder what you
think of that knowing what you had to go
through towards the end of your career
well i mean i think the one thing that i
would say is that you know we've got a
kind of a different breed of
quarterbacks um
you know kind of taking over the nfl now
you know the athletic quarterback uh the
guy that can do you know much more than
just throw the football and uh you know
i've always said about guys you know
like brees and and brady and those kind
of guys like myself um when you play a
certain way your entire career i think
it's easier to
and you still have the skill set to do
that so in other words all of us
obviously being pocket passers and not
based on our athleticism so it didn't
matter if we could throw the ball a few
yards less or we couldn't run the 40
quite as fast because we played it a
different way and so i always felt like
guys like that had the opportunity
to play the same way and have the same
success longer in their career um you
know so i think that's the first thing
and that's who tom was and he continued
to get better and better at what he did
but he never had to change the way that
he played i mean you had the rules in to
the mix
obviously that probably helped a little
bit but you know but but let's be honest
i mean it doesn't matter with all those
things
you know it came down to tom being
meticulous with
how he prepared and how he worked every
year and how he got his body ready i
mean you know the amazing thing is we
actually the year we went to the super
bowl with the cardinals was the year
that he suffered his knee injury so we
played new england that year and it was
matt castle and um you know and outside
of that one season and that crazy injury
the guy really hasn't you know had many
issues physically whatsoever which is
so amazing to me because i remember you
know through my career i didn't suffer a
lot of injuries but the injuries came
with like broken fingers and broken
pinkies and
everything on my right hand where i had
to miss time and miss games the guy just
didn't miss games and you know whether
he was fortunate uh whether it you know
plays into everything that he did off
the field to keep himself ready um i
mean just incredible to watch i mean you
know there was no way you know when i
was getting into the league
quarterbacks were retiring at 35 that
was a long career so you know 44 i just
with all these quarterbacks in the way
they play now i'm not sure anybody's
going to be able to make it to 44
unless they can play
inside the pocket and you know and again
we've got guys joe burrow you mentioned
it
you know we've got a number of other
guys that can do that to a degree but
can they sustain that at the level that
you need to to have that tom brady type
success um will be fascinating and those
guys that are athletic
you know they're going to have to evolve
and play the game differently if they
want to come anywhere close to the you
know to that age in my opinion
kurt warner here on the rich eisen show
um so i had the author seth wickersham
on the show in hour one kurt and he's
been following the patriots forever in a
day he's got a book out about their
dynasty
and i asked him about brady's decision
to retire now
and how i'm ki i was kind of surprised
by it for many reasons because he's been
so terrific but the fact is that you
know he he's not giving it one more try
to make sure he can end it on a win
right with a super bowl win
and here was his response and i'm
curious to hear your thoughts on the
other side check it out there was a
moment that
i was at his i was in his living room
and we were talking this is maybe seven
years ago it was before the sort of
rest of the dynasty which not only the
patriots but really the tom brady
dynasty
kind of
was reclamated and
he was telling me about they had just
lost to the ravens in the playoffs and
he told me that kurt warner had sent him
a text after the game saying like being
the best doesn't mean you always win it
just means you win more than anybody
else
and that text really meant a lot to him
because it
it spoke to his essence in a way that
very few messages could it
yes it's always about winning but it was
often in failure that he found successes
and
you know the the people there's people
who argued he'd never leave new england
after throwing a pick six on his final
throw
against the titans and there's people
who'd argue he'd never go out losing to
the los angeles rams in the playoffs but
you know that was
it it always misread him just a little
bit
i think that what he prided himself on
as much as anything
is this kind of genius he had of
refusing to concede anyone else's idea
of the inevitable or of reality in that
regard
what do you think of that
how about that
well i mean
you know i think it's something that we
all have to come to grips with is you
know so many of the guys that play at
this level are used to winning and
they're used to being the best
at what they do and
most times they feel like those two
things are synonymous
and you know as i mentioned earlier it's
also the ultimate team game
and so i tell people all the time
sometimes the greatest thing about being
a football player is that it's a team
game and you get to celebrate those
moments with 52 other guys and then
sometimes the worst thing about football
is that it's a team game because it
takes everybody and you know sometimes
other
facets can let you down and so i think
we all have to come to a realization of
what it means to be our best
and being our best doesn't always mean
that we win
on the scoreboard and that we have more
points than the other team and that gets
lost i think too often in society as a
whole
and you know just in sport in general
that it's all about how many points you
have on the board and you know and you
know when i text that and tom and i have
a great relationship and we would you
know text back and forth all the time
but really it was just just understand
who you are and what you've done and
don't ever you know you know feel like a
season can't be a success when you don't
finish winning a super bowl and um you
know so i love that you know you can
have those conversations with guys like
that that are the greatest of all time
and you can still impress upon them
things that you've learned throughout
your time and throughout your journey
because that to me is what it's all
about all of us evolving and coming to a
better understanding of what it means to
try to be our best on a daily basis and
then being able to step away and be
comfortable
that we were that and that we did what
we needed to do uh to become the best
version of ourselves which is what i
believe tom brady's always tried to do
kurt warner here on the rich eisenhower
before i let you go uh let's talk about
the film that you've seen from
championship weekend
um and um and then obviously the what
you saw with your own two eyes calling
the uh nfc championship game starting
with the afc championship i know you've
been watching tape on that one uh what
happened to that chief's offense in that
game kurt uh yeah i mean obviously you
know so many things you know go on in
the course of a game and you know
everybody saw the points on the board
early in the game and sometimes when i
watch film rich i'll watch and say okay
did something happen earlier in a game
that maybe leads to
something not happening happening as
well later in the game and what do i
mean by that you know in that game
patrick mahomes had um you know couple
touchdowns in the first half where it
was just unbelievable scramble plays by
him by in time and then he makes these
great throws and they get two touchdowns
out of it later in the game they had an
opportunity a couple opportunities in
the red zone um where if patrick i think
just reads the the play the way that he
normally would read it uh i think he
throws a couple touchdowns there and we
may be talking about them in the super
bowl um and one specifically he got
caught up kind of bouncing in the pocket
almost like i'm not really reading
anything i'm just buying time
enough so i can go and scramble and make
a play
and so i think sometimes we fall into
modes where things have worked earlier
in the game
and we try to force something
later in the game um you know the
interception that he threw off of that
you know the rpo the tip to the
defensive lineman uh it was actually an
rpo that normally you would read the
other side you're reading the the right
defensive end and if he bites down you
throw it out the right hand side because
they voided that area for some reason
patrick decided to to go and throw it to
the left hand side away from his read um
and and throw it to the combination the
quick combination that was out the left
instead of the right which is just again
i know it's happened to him before and
he's seen it look and it's worked out
but instead of just kind of playing the
play
um you know he tried to make another
play and it worked out against them and
so um that to me is what kind of
happened is that everything was going
right and they were making every play
early on it felt like they were
invincible so starting with that last
play at the end of the first half which
i'm still kind of confused by the play
call but you know i think it was patrick
saying man everything else is working so
let me just throw it to tyrique and
he'll make it work because cause we're
invincible right now and then after he
makes that throw it's like oh wait a
second that wasn't the right decision
and
he got a little more tentative and you
know i think he started thinking about
the game more than just reacting and
playing um and then things just didn't
work out for them in the second half and
the momentum switched
and you give credit to the other side
for making the plays that were available
in front of them to make whether it was
defensively or offensively joe burrow
making some key plays really with his
legs that we talked about on our show is
that he's kind of sneaky good at you
know buying time in the pocket and
avoiding sacks in the pocket and even if
he gains three or four yards it's a
positive instead of a negative and that
was really kind of the you know the
story of the second half in my opinion
um you know that i thought cincinnati
played good um but i thought you know
kansas city just didn't do what they
normally do and you know patrick was the
first one to kind of say hey some of
that stuff's on me that patrick didn't
play his game the second half and when
you're playing against good teams and
you allow some of those things and to go
against you
and it it's tough to win and that's what
we've seen throughout these playoffs is
that all these games are close
okay who's going to make that one
mistake or who's going to do something
that's uncharacteristic of themselves
give the other team a chance and then
the other team all these teams have the
chance to capitalize on it and then
what's the story of the nfc championship
game
i mean i think the nfc championship game
um
you know i think it was just a tough
fought football game where again there
were some missed opportunities by the
rams in that game that kept the 49ers
around i know everybody's killing jimmy
g i thought jimmy g played one of his
best games
but we're going to point out you know a
couple things obviously that the mispass
in the first drive which i know he'd
want back and then the one to kettle
you're talking about the one to kill
yeah the wonder kid oh he was so wide
open
that could have gone for six um and then
obviously the last one where i mean he
had to try to do something he's just
trying to make a play so it's not you
know fourth and forty right um and the
ball gets tipped up and you know but i
thought jimmy g played a really really
good game uh making the right decision
uh most of the time um but you know but
the rams to me were the better team
matthew stafford is playing great
football um you know made the one
mistake in the red zone that turned into
an interception or you know who knows
how that game goes but jalen ramsey has
two opportunities to catch an
interception that possibly finished that
game uh before that we're all talking
about tarte's interception and the one
you know or one of the two mistakes that
that stafford made um but you know jalen
ramsey had a chance to finish that game
i just think the better team were the
rams
49ers you know did what they needed to
do and kept it close like they had up to
this point uh in all their games but
just weren't able to finish and i give
more credit to the rams offensively what
they did three straight drives in the
fourth quarter to put points on the
board you tip your hat to them cooper
cup and stafford were incredible obj was
great and then the defense did what you
brought all those guys here to do is you
got a lead at the end finish it for us
and they went out and they finished it
for him and so a good football game on
that side uh but again i believe the
better team won um and you know the rams
made enough plays to get a tight victory
well uh but you know appreciate the time
here kurt uh rolling with the punches
with the show today and we're in in
getting you on um i hope to get you on
maybe sometime next week in the lead up
to to know what you think about the
match-up um and i appreciate the two
cents i thought it was pretty cool to
hear that story about
your text to brady you know sometimes
you send a text to somebody you don't
know what you know what it means or how
it lands or something like that and
here here we are years later on the day
of his retirement and um somebody who
knows brady pretty well is saying that
meant a lot to him so that's pretty cool
yeah you know i mean that that stuff is
cool because again you're you know
always just trying to build
relationships and
uh you know different things along the
way and you never know you never know
how it's going to play out exactly and
since especially since on game day
morning you're known as somebody who
does not get his texts returned by
quarterbacks um so i felt good actually
that becomes how you you guys remember
me american underdog in theaters near
you how's that did i make up for it
right now okay
everybody go see kurt's movie it's a
beautiful movie kurt and brenda's movie
my bad good to see uh chat with you kurt
we'll do this again everybody thanks man
it's the best that's the one of the best
of all time right there and a huge
fantastic friend uh kurt warner right
here